build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
Creations from Everyday People this is
bdp building Rick Hamill built a 7t RC
fire breathing dragon it flies with a
turbine engine and has a wingspan of 9
ft the dragon's head is slaved into the
rudder and helps it turn and the fire is
liquid propane ignited by a stun gun
circuit built into the jaw Scott 5 makes
cardboard busts of pop culture and
historical figures the seattle-based
artist uses cardboard screws and glue to
create the busts and he initially
decided to use cardboard as a medium for
economic reasons and his Works include a
young Abraham Lincoln Elvis and popey
building a helmet worthy of a dovak is
Shannon clawen he specializes in
creating armor and weaponry and this scy
skrim inspired helmet is fabricated from
16 gauge steel and took about a month to
make the horns are carved out of wood
find the link below to watch the whole
video the inebriator is an Arduino
powered homemade cocktail machine it's
stocked with vodka rum tequila Jin
several cordials along with mixers like
orange juice cranberry and grenadine
they say the automated process creates
the perfect cocktail every time and
they're currently working on a new
version draw Australian artist wbk
creates celebrity keyboard portraits the
mosaics use a mix of analog and digital
keyboard pieces including typewriter
Keys calculator buttons and old type
sets and his portraits include Hugh Lor
Bono and Dr Dre carity is an
illustration containing over 2500 pop
culture characters created by New York
artist Ray suer the massive drawing
contains characters ranging from video
games and Disney to breakfast cereal
mascots Simpsons Star Wars and a ton
more find the link below to check the
whole thing out and zoom in to the many
different characters and now for some
amazing art from the Press Start video
game Exhibition at LTD
gallery
Von pinpin recently Illustrated a lineup
of first generation Pokemon in the style
of Tim Burton including Squirtle
Bulbasaur and
Charizard play it Canadian artist Martin
Messier used computers and sewing
machines from the 1940s to create the
sewing machine
orchestra electrochemistry is a remix
made by G using footage from Dexter's
Lab
laboratory the piano Cade is a chip tune
style synthesizer and MIDI controller
that's open source and designed to be
easily
hacked I need one more play it bdp so do
you have any friends in bands Amy polar
hey Vsauce thanks for the question Kevin
I do have one person that comes to mind
Kathleen Hannah who was in a great band
called Bikini Kill and latigra uh
there's this latigra song Decepticon
that I would recommend to all your
viewers it really gets you
going every
day every day night
submit your own bdps as a personal
message here on YouTube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucegaming
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bdp Radio Music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your bdp an entire video dedicated to
your Creations oh and if you like
Kathleen Hannah you can see her at one
of our dance parties in one of our
episodes of smart girls at the party
which is on our SMART Girls channel that
we hope you check out so if you're smart
and a girl check out Amy's Channel smart
girls make make sure you subscribe and
as always thanks for
watching not alone I'm not
alone in this
world but I so alone I'm so
world